Vamos a pensar un poco,
¿qué obtenemos de la multiplicación
y de la suma de dos números racionales?
si yo empiezo con el producto,
con la multiplicación
de dos números racionales
y supongamos que uno
que se llama "a" entre "b",
tengo al número "a" entre "b"
y a éste...
Oh, que fea "b"...
"a" entre "b"
y a éste lo voy a multiplicar
por otro número que sea racional,
se me ocurre
"m" entre "n",
bueno cuando
multiplico estos 2,
¿qué voy a obtener?
Esto es exactamente lo mismo
que "a" por "m"...
que "a" por "m" recuerda
que se multiplican así las fracciones,
"a" por "m",
ok,
y a esto dividido
entre "b" por "n"...
déjame cambiar de color...
"b" por "n"...
por "n"...
Ahora date cuenta que si "a" entre "b" es
un número racional
y "m" entre "n"
es un número irracional,
"a" es un número entero
y "m" es un número entero,
por lo tanto
cuando multiplique
dos números enteros,
voy a obtener
también un número entero
y de igual manera
va a pasar con los denominadores,
"b" es un número entero,
"n" es un número entero
y por lo tanto "b" por "n"
es un número entero,
como tengo la razón
o la proporción,
estoy comparando
dos números enteros,
entonces puedo decir
que este número de aquí
también es racional...
éste también es racional...
ok, de lujo,
si me tomo la multiplicación
de dos números racionales,
obtengo un número
racional.
Ahora vamos a cambiar de color
y vamos a pensar en números racionales
cuando se suman.
Supongamos que tengo
"a" entre "b", ok,
y a esto le voy a sumar...
le voy a sumar otro número racional
y para seguir con esta misma lógica
voy a tomarme a "m" entre "n",
ok, ¿qué obtengo de la
suma de estos dos racionales?
Bueno, para tomarme
la suma de estos dos racionales,
pues hay varias formas de hacerlo,
lo primero que se me ocurre es que
podríamos tomar un denominador común
y el denominador común
va a ser "b" por "n",
voy a tomar como
denominador común a "b" por "n"...
vamos a poner esta línea aquí...
"b" por "n"...
"b" por "n", ok,
y bueno, para saber qué me va a quedar
aquí arriba,
lo que necesito hacer es convertir a esta fracción
en algo que tenga
un denominador común
de "b" por "n"
y para eso voy a multiplicar
tanto arriba como abajo por "n"...
tanto arriba como
abajo por "n", ok...
de tal manera que ya tengo
el denominador común que yo quería
y ahora sí, voy a tener
"bn" entre "bn" es "an"...
déjame ponerlo así...
"a" por "n", ok,
y a esto le voy a sumar,
le voy a sumar
y ahora me voy a fijar
en esta fracción,
si me fijo
en esta fracción de aquí,
lo que me falta para tener
este denominador común, "bn"
es multiplicar tanto arriba como abajo por "b",
entonces multipliquemos por "b" y por "b",
de tal manera que
abajo tengo ya "nb" o "bn"
y arriba me queda "m" por "b"...
y lo voy a poner con este color...
"m" por "b"...
por "b"...
De tal manera que quiero que te des cuenta
de algo muy importante con esta expresión
que tengo aquí.
En la parte de abajo, tengo el producto de
dos números enteros
y en la parte de arriba
tengo un número entero,
la multiplicación de 2 enteros es 1 entero
más otro entero
y 1 entero más otro entero
también es un número entero...
Por lo tanto, éste de aquí...
éste de aquí,
es lo mismo que 1 entero
entre otro entero,
lo cual es lo mismo que una razón
de 2 números enteros
o una proporción de 2 números enteros
o estamos comparando
2 números enteros,
lo cual me dice
que es un número racional...
racional...
Y está de lujo,
ya me estoy dando cuenta
que si tengo la multiplicación o el producto
de 2 números racionales,
obtengo racional
y por otra parte si me tomo la suma de 2 números
racionales también obtengo un racional.